how Cambria my name is Pierre my welcome
back to limbo it's a jolly game but a
man with glowing eyes yes you little
[ __ ] where did you go the other time I
ordered yeah
I specifically prepared don't behave to
me your little person all right double
box pushing even naughty boxes naughty
naughty
all right we just need one on each floor
it's pretty [ __ ] simple see if I can
time this no I [ __ ] can't
well maybe I can no I [ __ ] can't all
right there we go
[ __ ] it oh [ __ ]
I really have to time it why do are you
doing this to me why I have to think
even here well fine all right here's the
plan
una box of directed por ter sauce and
then
all right how's the forest as far as
this go there all right
so too far baby now and then one chill
no this is not correct
I'll do it when it comes back hey baby
baby why don't you just [ __ ] about says
hey Dad yeah barely stacks a god
[ __ ] you boxes [ __ ] yeah deader than 10
Ton Ton Ton Ton Ton Ton Ton Ton Ton Ton
nothing can kill me I am invincible
Sarah gasps mother why didn't Denton
Darren don't under magnet time didn't
intend to do da dun dun dun dun dun dun
dun why what am I doing here oh I get it
I get it
hmm
oh I got it
yes
hey as penny strikes again
[ __ ] where's my Nobel Prize man where
is it ah really a Nobel Prize now wait
I'm I want to finish this game
stupid gordon freeman came here and
wanted to give me a Nobel Prize playing
limbo all right what do we got here it's
not stupid though it's really beautiful
I would make one food nothing all right
you're supposed to grab it I thought you
liked dangling things oh I get it
I got it dad done done done done it
never mind never mind I don't get it
community little peanuts y-you know grab
it bro oh I get it get it done done done
and get it done done done done get it
done ha ha ha ha yes yes limbo boy we
did it did it did it oh look oh oh oh
come here baby come here baby don't you
run away from me don't you dare run away
from it yard Dada Dada Dada Dada Dada
jump off Jesus Christ oh my god that was
epic slide that shut jump over here I'm
gonna die I'm gonna die
what am i sposta doubt yes I'll have to
redo everything ah ok it Charles mythic
the [ __ ] sign is trolling me ah bad
oh there's a rope then I get it I get it
I get it
and it open up my eyes that's jump like
[ __ ] baby girl why don't you just grab
it it's right there oh no I don't hurt
oh yeah
then we judge I was fun Oh Oh my nipple
baby
oh I don't even know what a nipple face
is this is perfect if you wanna die
god [ __ ] damnit this jump I cannot
make this jump why don't you just feel
like it hey da what if I ah [ __ ] you
gang
[ __ ] you I am NOT a fan anymore
ah nevermind I love you ha ha ha
nice going Jerry oh come on that was aa
nearly got Electrify okay one of those
tests I fell bit that I've done ten
pattern gonna turn out a dad good job
Jerry I love you have iris told you that
one time that I love you cuz I do love
you Jerry I do love you oh so very much
the hell is this [ __ ] am I supposed
to spend this don't die please we're
alive that's a miracle I don't believe
it
he's [ __ ] arrows man how could I not
see that don't hit me bucks what are you
doing it I changed my mind I don't want
to be here anymore
what dead oh don't don't don't
don know how everything is according to
plan
oh no oh no yes baby yes sexist Texas
struck me and you do the kind of [ __ ]
that homie breaker breaker back up a
gamma hang and now back up enough yes
I'm Cisco yes I'm a father I'm a do any
poop doctor you had enough fun to wait
on your rowdy ragout
I want you to I'd you like you covered
ACMA waffle hmm god damn it and write
down color overlay for me bring my
camera
Ryan Dodger can be a coverage now why
are they just like cooking don't die
please not today not today not today
yeah not today knocked it okay we did it
today but whatever I just going on here
that guy does not listen
oh that's good ah my gosh ha ha ha I did
not mean to do that
get up whoa what change to gravity
Afghan don't get me oh my gosh hold I
have three now so it's this random
whenever it changes yeah I hear the
sound now the flash
all right not everything in life goes as
planned
Oh mlj major oh wow
okay well I get the print seep now
all right I got it I'm such a [ __ ]
genius where's Morgan Freeman and that
what
oh you bet I do is Wyatt Wyatt we were
doing so good together jump up there I
don't have time for this [ __ ]
all right what now we can't fail now
take me off
country road to the place where I belong
limbo Jerry
why are you a sighted masochist no Jack
meow ha ha ha this is so difficult
okay not that oh oh you want the
controller but you can't have it
no sigh my simple go ha ha ha yes yes
yes yes yes you are doing it correct
Carl take me down I do not want to be
here anymore don't kill me please I have
a know I miss sex ow
alright alright alright I am closer
you're gonna make it you're not gonna
make it this time
this time I'm gonna [ __ ] your face ha ha
ha oh oh nu nu nu t the Podesta did the
panic da look at death baby
what is his slow mo action vs. get epic
sama what wow that was a lot of work
that was a lot of work for me I didn't
see there was a [ __ ] glass wall there
no I didn't you know why because it's a
[ __ ] I did he die or some [ __ ] did we
make it
the gravity' still should go there
technically maybe the only applies where
the light is then it doesn't apply
technically he broke his legs it comes a
time in every man's life
well you just have to go and break
through walls or go through limbo Jerry
was one of those persons
Jerry Jerry wanted to be a giant
ecologist but things just never work out
the way you expect them to be I think we
all learned a lesson here in life if you
want to look at vaginas that dream may
never come true and you might end up in
limbo
okay that was good
sorry hey about Jerry Jerry I love you I
will not forget this I will kill all the
boxes for you all the boxes I can relate
to this problem that you're having did I
seriously just finish the game or is he
gonna come back up a lot I think we're
gonna see those eyes glowing again no no
do you see it Rose do you see it do you
[ __ ] see it the game [ __ ] ends
just at this begins this is exactly how
it looks like no please tell me there is
more to this we are actually a limbo the
title makes sense
no I live please please don't don't do
this to me
oh yes yes thank you
I would have [ __ ] killed something
Jesus it's not our sister or is it our
lover I wish it was a lover but you know
and that it ends that was awesome that
ending made me [ __ ] [ __ ] my pants
beautiful beautiful I love when I I was
nice I actually would have maybe like
that even more
it'd be the same way Danish people have
made this game that's cool that's cool I
didn't know Danish people can do stuff
no fun alright what is going on here
alright epic let's play I think you bros
loved it I loved it lads let's do
something different
I'm I'm glad you depressed like that
because it's a [ __ ] puzzle game who
would have thought that I
and we could make that happen that
compares enjoyed subscribe to come over
today and I'll see you next episode that
violin take another breath
alright mode that [ __ ] safety system my
ass
yeah
oh [ __ ]